وبعده مخزونات العتاد العسكريه الامريكي
وصلت للحد الادنى من المستويات المطلوبه
لتنفيذ خطه الحرب والتدريب والمناوره فاين
ذهب مخزون اكبر سلاح مملوك للدوله في
العالم حسب دراسه عسكريه نشرتها وسطى جونل
واشنطن تعاني من تحدي لرفع مستوى صناعاتها
الدفاعيه في وقت تنظم فيه مخزوناتها
العسكريه السبب الابرز الذي وضع امريكا في
مازقه واستنزافه اوكرانيا بعض مخزوناتها
من السلاح حيث استهلكت اوكرانيا سبع سنوات
من انتاج امريكا لصواريخ جافلين بالاضافه
الى استهلاكها لما يوازي ما صدرته امريكا
خلال 20 عاما من صواريخ ستينجر
الولايات المتحده لارسال اكثر من 27 مليار
دولار من المعدات العسكريه الى اوكرانيا
وضعت واشنطن نفسها في موقف لا تحسد عليه
مركز دراسات الاستراتيجيه والدوليه
[موسيقى]
تجاه اوكرانيا جعل مخزونها من الترسانه
العسكريه بوضع حرج وخطر استراتيجي
في وقت الحرب
ستواجه مشكله في الذخيره تؤثر على قدرتها
على حمايه نفسها او خلفائها عسكريه وهو ما
قد يغير قواعد المواجهه حسب المركز
الامريكي في وقت تجد شركه الدفاع نفسها
غير قادره على استرجاع المخزونات
المستنفذه بسرعه او موكبه المفاجاه
العسكريه